hey
how was your day great the uh toaster
broke and rose refused to eat her
vegetables
how did it go at the dentist the dentist
don't tell me you forgot about the
dentist appointment no i didn't forget i
thought you were taking her tomorrow no
it was today i'm working tomorrow but
it's saturday i know i've got to work
overtime you have to do that every week
oh cody i'm not in the mood for this
discussion again hey hey rose needs both
of us okay
that's not fair
using her i'm not using her i'm just
stating a fact
why don't we just go ahead and tell her
that we're divorcing oh just like that
yeah
may this
isn't it
let's not tell her
let's stay friends instead
yes
let's stay friends forever
i love you cody
i love you too mae
[Music]
hey honey
can i just take elephant a sec all right
uh
rose
honey you know we love you right
yeah
and sometimes that means that uh
we have to do stuff that isn't always
very
fun
what we're trying to say darling is that
well
mum and dad
we've decided to go our separate ways
[Music]
okay
can i go and play in my room
uh
yeah yeah of course
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr hakeem you have to help me now
they have to stay together
look
it says here love is work see
you have to work on it
you can't just give up
mom dad
i wish you could be friends again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hey is that you
tony
why'd you look like a blob of clay why
do you look like a wooden doll
[Music]
what have you done what what why do you
always blame me huh
yes why do you always blame him thank
you oh oh
what is that
i'm dr hockey worldwide best seller and
an expert on love
your daughter purchased me she was lucky
i was the last copy because i was
selling the best
i kept millions of couples and now i
will help you too to get together again
this is definitely a nightmare
i need to wake up
[Music]
oh you're back
oh my god you can't wake up here exactly
okay um mr um
book
so uh how do you wake up cody may you're
here to fix your relationship we just
fixed it yeah yeah we're uh divorcing
it's all good
no
i will help you fix your relationship
chapter
one
fix your relationship
plus
i promised your daughter to fix your
marriage
see love is like a mountain
river mate mate it's rose flowers
come on let's get down
she must know what's going on
butterflies floating in the mountains
like lovebirds you know what i'm saying
hello hello
how do we get up to her oh the stairs
over there but we can't reach them we're
tiny well let's find a way
uh they're alive what is going on here i
have no clue
but whatever's going on
we can't lower that staircase without
those fuses
but
those fuses
they just
they just ran away i mean did you see
them on their little fused legs worry
about that later
let's just bring them back
[Music]
hey
hey my body feels weird
because you're made of clay
keep your eyes on the fuses okay
don't you feel weird i mean no made of
wood
a bit stiff
same here but it's getting better the
more i move i hope so
please focus all right all right
let's get those fuses
[Music]
[Music]
oh get back here
i don't like the sound of that
me neither
[Music]
hmm
cody watch your head
i am i
am
back
hey let's do this together
okay yeah okay
you please coordinate with me cody
all right all right
ah
uh
maybe that container can help
whoa i think this power's up the saw
yeah
let's check it out
cody let's go what are you waiting for
[Applause]
wow
hey may did you see my flip let's do it
again we're not here to do flips oh no
you're right this is serious
we're hunting fuses with legs all right
this is the last one let's put it in
oh
huh
hmm
huh
[Music]
oh
perfect let's go
what just what just happened oh those
damn fuses oh may
there she is
rose oh
rose darling
oh
god not you again move out of the way
you stupid book yeah get out of the way
i need to go and talk to my daughter
just your daughter oh you talk like you
own her ask yourself can you really own
the people you love you just let us
through come on i will but first there's
someone i want you to meet
cha cha cha cha cha
oh
what the hell is that
why do i recognize your voice me oh what
no
we've uh we've never met
sorry looks a bit like a vacuum cleaner
oh yeah because it is your vacuum
cleaner
yo vacuum que pasa you know who this guy
is let me tell you this is cody you know
the guy could suck up all kinds of crap
in your stomach oh
no that's uh that's you
you ruined my bowels with all that crap
crap what i was just sucking up dust
that was it just
come
[Music]
you on that just
well i mean you know some of it it's so
that's why it broke down it was your
fault oh and you promised him you'd fix
me thank you
instead you put me away for life in here
you want to get back to rose yes you
want to talk to your daughter yes
and you need to climb the vacuum
together oh come on why are you doing
this to us because you two must learn
collaboration that's not all strong
points
you know collaboration is the key to a
successful relationship
huh
collaboration
you understand
now
this would never have happened if you
hadn't broken it oh yeah well this would
never have happened if you had fixed it
like you promised well i didn't know
we'd end up in a place where our vacuum
cleaners alive well now we are
maybe we're stuck here forever forever
no way we're getting a divorce i know
we're getting a divorce but we can't do
that unless we get back into our real
bodies okay
let's climb that damn vacuum cleaner
you know
i wonder where that annoying book even
came from
he said rose bought him
[Music]
you know
self-help books are very important to
some people okay forget about the book
hey
jump inside the halls
ah try not to drop me
you want to try aiming
[Music]
hey
what we're doing
[Music]
oh
oh
all right the current has reversed
what is that
that was kind of fun actually
not bad
after you
don't let go
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
damn too slow
[Music]
that was totally worth some elections
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ugh
this looks dangerous
just time your jumps
all right give it a whirl
[Music]
people
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh is this a fire hazard
[Music]
[Music]
alright
[Music]
huh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was a little too much
[Music]
huh
[Music]
hey
ah
ah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey get down here vacuum
ah i think we can use some of this dust
and
other stuff
[Music]
huh
oh
i'm gonna pull my back
you destroyed my digestion
and you put me away to rot in here
no you will go die no wait
i can still fix you i can make you work
again no more
no no no lies
right she's an engineer a really good
one you are you're very good
hey thank you are you really gonna
believe that huh because i would not
don't listen to him once i get my real
body back i can fix you oh
is that so
then why did you buy the expensive turbo
x2000 huh hey
what
you've replaced me with the turbo x 2
000
a pretentious french vacuum who can't
even suck drop a lie
i'll show you who's the best sucker
[Music]
oh okay i'm out of here see you later
good luck
come on
check on this
no one replaces me
oh
[Music]
keep going
i don't want this
that doesn't sound good
for you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
for you
he stopped yeah
time to finish this
you're punching us the wrong way
sorry vacuum
[Music]
come on we have to find rose before she
leaves i hope she knows what's happened
to us well she must know something she
made these dolls
she made these yeah
well why did she make them look like us
i don't know
why didn't you tell me about them oh why
would i she's a kid she plays with all
kinds of stuff
yeah
oh come on let's find her
where are we
you should know
you use this place i haven't been in
here for ages
plus
everything looks different yeah
it's like some
twisting version of reality
yeah
it's like
some twisted version of reality
hey
over here
oh look it's rose rose honey
rose
she can't
she can't hear us
oh no
how are we gonna get over there now
i can help what what was that
who was it i don't know
over here
look
i know the way come
on i'll take you there if you help me
save my friends well friends my tool
friends we used to be important and
taken care of but that human locked us
up in our toolbox and left you mean maze
toolbox yes yes that heartless woman do
you know her well no he doesn't anyway i
heard that heartless woman got a new job
in town and doesn't have time for our
hobbies anymore who cares about hobbies
do you know how painful it is to die
from rust
it's like
burning alive slowly slowly look at
hammer there's some rust remover spray
in that tool cabinet we can help save
your friends but only if you can get us
to rose over there okay it's a deal pick
me up
okay now go to that big door over there
pull that nail out we're gonna need it
okay here it goes
whoa
where'd it go just whistle what really
oh cool
we got a flying nail and a talking
hammer
let's go
hey look that's all right
be careful with that nail cody i don't
want it in my eye okay well don't drop
that hammer on my toe don't worry i know
how to handle things oh yeah well me too
last time you used a hammer you smashed
your own thumb yeah well
but i'm in charge of the nail now okay
okay
just be careful
[Music]
hey maybe we can swing off that nail
steady now
sweet moves i like your style man oh
thanks hammer
this is so satisfying
[Music]
there's another nail let's go get it uh
yoo-hoo
still over here hello the bridge please
sweet more ammunition
easy on me
[Music]
hmm
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
there are no relationships without
challenges challenges make you grow but
is it with you can't you just leave us
alone
when you're willing to face a challenge
you always learn something new
so remember when you hear
this sound
follow it keep following it and you will
find the challenge you seek
yeah
welcome to your first couples challenge
win or lose you must do it together
uh
well i guess we're gonna have to
all right you want to give it a try we
haven't got time for this oh are you
afraid of losing
me
no way
bring it on oh i'm gonna bring it
hey cody over here
watch your head cody oh you won't beat
me i'm faster than a mole my ham is
faster than that
peekaboo
easy
you
missed it
[Music]
all righty
ah i got this
that's it
[Music]
i knew it i'm too fast for you i'll beat
you next time
ah the sweet sounds of machinery there's
nothing better
hold on tight
there's another machine in the way here
cody
i think i'm gonna be sick
[Music]
look at him fly
uh
be careful now may yeah
cody
don't screw this
yeah
cody
don't screw this up yeah yeah just get
the jumping
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
nice one
free
[Music]
[Music]
hero slide
ugh
got it that makes three
gonna need a boost mate
oh great
oh great another trust exercise what
you think i'm gonna miss i hope not
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you know you do have pretty good
teamwork
i don't know about that
thanks
[Music]
all right mate bring the hammer over
here
[Music]
[Music]
we're coming to save you
you'll never get away with this you
stupid toolbox
oh
but you're a bit heavy-headed
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
oh
uh
[Music]
wow
heads up
this oh bad
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
watch out
ah
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you're going down
[Music]
oh
that's gotta hurt
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
negotiating cody
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
finish up
hey get me back up there
oh
[Music]
oh
yes i'm ready i'm so ready for this oh
it tickles it
[Music]
there tickles go thank you
i feel brand new
look at me
you saved us from that rust and toolbox
thank you may you are a true hero oh
thank you hammer hey what about me huh i
was part of this too where's my hero
love did you see that explosion anyway
we still have to get to rose oh of
course of course sebastian can you help
him out they have to get to the other
side
flexible huh
step on board
really okay you sure come on it's safe
hey oop this doesn't feel safe i'm not
sure just relax
okay
don't worry he's very precise sebastian
slinging
[Music]
oh no
she's leaving rose wait we need your
help
[Music]
oh you stupid buck oh you've locked us
in you idiot now we're stuck in here
stuckness he's a mental construct if you
stare at the closed door you will miss
the one that's open
okay fyi there is only one door in this
shed and one window good thinking man
let's go to the window whoa
book is out of his mind okay
[Music]
yeah very cool but just don't fall off
ah don't worry i'm pretty good at this
[Music]
we need to time this together all right
one more time
oh
holy crap focus here he comes
[Music]
look it's your old binoculars amazing
let's find rose
oh rose uh
yeah yeah we uh we need to find her
oh yes i know we look like dolls but
we're actually her parents
i know who you are
nothing escapes my lenses
look
what in in here all right okay um
let's see
[Music]
oh i look dead
am i dead you're not dead
what's going on
oh no
what's the matter with
all us know is that rose sat down there
with her dolls and then you two came
alive
just like that
you didn't see anything else well there
was one unusual thing why what happened
she was crying
oh i know quite unusual for rose but i
am a hundred percent sure because i
could see her tears falling onto the
dolls
tears were falling onto the dolls
oh wait a minute
i know what happened
it's a spell
ridiculous cody we've got to apply logic
may okay we are having a conversation
with a pair of binoculars
there is no logic in that goodness sake
i don't even believe in spells okay well
did you believe that you could be turned
into a wooden doll huh
exactly
it had to be the tears
it was a spell i am telling you
so
if it is a spell
how do we break it okay i got this yeah
me and rose we read all about the spell
stuff i'm a virtual wizard right now
okay just give me some space i need to
think
okay so if the spell was cast through
her tears then in order to break it
oh
in order to break it
we have to
reverse it through her tears
boom right
okay
we basically have to find her and make
her cry on us again
really
okay
fine okay
do you know where to find her miss
binoculars
she's in her room
go on
okay thanks uh come on mate
how do we get to a room from here easy
we just climbed the tree
you